drei Jahre dauert ihre Ausbildung am
Ende dürfen sie sich Pflegefachfrau oder
pflegefachmann nennen im letzten Jahr
entschieden sich mehr als 53.000
Menschen für diesen Beruf ein leichtes
Plus von 5% gegenüber dem Vorjahr aber
nicht alle schließen die Ausbildung auch
ab die Abbrecherquote gilt als hoch der
Alltag in Krankenhäusern und Altenheim
stressig belasten viel zu wenig Zeit für
die Versorgung von Patientinnen und
älteren Menschen arbeiten am Limit sagt
die Mehrzahl der Pflegenden bis Mitte
Juli streikte das Personal an den
Unikliniken in NRW 11 Wochen lang für
bessere Arbeitsbedingungen nach wie vor
entscheiden sich hauptsächlich Frauen
für den Beruf viele beginnen die
Ausbildung erst ab 30
Pflegefachkraft trotz Probleme ein
vielseitiger und sinnstiftender Beruf
betont der Pflegerat doch durch die
Pandemie hätte die Belastung in
Einrichtungen noch zugenommen so die
Kritik seit zwe anderthalb Jahren gilt
für Pflegende tagein Tag aus Masken und
testpflicht
und was wurden gerade zu Beginn der
Pandemie die Pflegekräfte beklatscht
kaufen können Sie sich davon aber nichts
auch die Arbeitszeiten und
Arbeitsbedingungen haben sich dadurch
natürlich nicht verbessert
problem on top auch die geringen
Aufstiegschancen sorgen dafür dass viele
Stellen im Pflegebereich unbesetzt
bleiben die Präsidentin des Deutschen
pflegerates ist jetzt bei mir Christina
Vogler es gibt also einiges zu
besprechen erstmal schönen guten Morgen
schönen guten Morgen
was bringt denn das
pflegeentlastungsgesetz
alles was der Pflege gut tun soll und
auf den Weg gebracht wird begrüßen wir
natürlich aber wir müssen natürlich
hinschauen was wird an welchen Schrauben
wird gedreht und die großen Dinge an
denen wir immer drehen wollen und wo wir
auch Ideen haben die wir einbringen an
denen wird nicht gedreht zum Beispiel
zum Beispiel die Kompetenzen der
Pflegenden im in ihrer Arbeit auch
würdigen und auch ausüben lassen am
Beispiel impfen ist das so eine
Situation wir sagen Tierärzte und
Apotheker werden jetzt geschult zum
Impfen jeden Tag gehen 100.000 von
Pflegefachpersonen in die ambulante
Versorgung wenn wir das machen könnten
was wir auch tatsächlich können aber
impfen dürfen wir nicht das sind Sachen
die immer europäischen Ausland zum
Beispiel ganz selbstverständlich sind in
Deutschland heißt das so Heilkunde
Übertragung das ist etwas was wir seit
Jahren fordern aber ist denn das
pflegeentlastungsgesetz auch eine
Verbesserung für die Arbeitsbedingungen
man hört ja immer wieder dass viele
Pflegekräfte sagen es geht gar nicht so
sehr ums Geld sondern wir haben diesen
Beruf
ausgeübt gelernt etc weil wir den
Menschen helfen wollen wir haben aber
keine Zeit die Bürokratie steht uns im
Weg und vieles mehr also wird das eine
Entlastung bringen wir haben ja die
Situation dass wir in Deutschland am
meisten Krankenhausbetten haben aber den
schlechtesten Personalschlüssel gemessen
daran sieht man schon da stimmt
irgendwas im System nicht und an der
Stelle hilft auch das
pflegeentlastungsgesetz tatsächlich
nicht wir haben jetzt natürlich die
tarifsituation in die Unikliniken das
ist zu begrüßen zu sagen wir brauchen
mehr Pflegefachpersonen aber wir müssen
auf das gesamte pflegerische Feld
schauen in der ambulanten Versorgung die
Kolleginnen die brauchen auch
angemessene Bezahlung das und das immer
spannend wenn gesagt wird naja am Geld
liegt ja nicht so fragen Sie die
Menschen die hier sind liegt es am Geld
ich weiß es nicht also letztendlich
liegt am Ende auch am Geld wir haben
eine ungleichmäßige Bezahlung im
pflegerischen versorgungsfeld und das
muss zum Beispiel auch angegangen werden
und auch wirklich schlechte
Personalschlüssel im Bereich der
altenpflegeversorgung weil sie gerade
Krankenhaus angesprochen haben wir haben
ja das MoMA Café mit Zuschauer
ZuschauerInnen und bei Andreas sitzt
jemand die glaube ich auch weiß wovon
sie Frau Vogler gerade sprechen ja und
Rainer Zufall dass wir Margitta Reetz
hier kennengelernt haben erstmal
herzlich willkommen im Morgenmagazin
im Urlaub in Berlin aber im Alltag
Ärztin und Professoren am Klinikum
rechts der Isar in München also vom Fach
und sie können uns natürlich berichten
wie der Alltag bei Ihnen im Haus oder
auch in ihrem Arbeitsalltag aussieht wie
hoch ist die Belastung in der Pflege
also ich muss sagen das ist im Moment
stehen wir eigentlich ehrlich gesagt vor
allem Kollaps es ist tatsächlich so dass
wir ich kann auch aus unserer Station
sprechen ich bin Urologin wir machen
Krebspatienten überwiegend Versorgung
sowohl in der Chemotherapie als auch in
der Operation wir haben insgesamt 65
Betten wir haben aktuell 15 Wetten
gestrichen weil wir keine Pflege haben
das bedeutet aber auch wieder im
Umkehrschluss wir können keine Patienten
annehmen und wenn Sie sich vorstellen
dass ich sehr sehr viele Patienten
bekomme gerade Patienten die sehr schwer
krank sind die brauchen eine Chemo oder
Immuntherapie vielleicht sogar ein
Operation die muss sich abweisen die
können wir nicht annehmen
und wenn dann man fragt na ja wie sieht
es denn aus mit der zweiten
Universitätsklinik da muss ich sagen
auch die haben keine Möglichkeit
das ist sehr sehr dramatisch und ich
muss sagen Hut ab vor die Pflege die
machen teilweise Doppelschichten bis zu
16 Stunden und das ist
selbstverständlich dass die natürlich
auch keine Lust mehr haben also durchaus
dramatisch vielen Dank dass Sie das uns
kurz geschildert haben und wir nehmen
das einfach mit ins Gespräch mit Dunja
ja und wenn man sich diese Zustände
anhört und das wissen ja die meisten
fragt man sich immer wie kann das
eigentlich passieren bei uns in
Deutschland wo es möglicherweise am Geld
nicht mangelt aber die Frage ist ja
jetzt wie kann man die Attraktivität für
die Pflegeberufe sie haben schon gesagt
es ist ja vielfältig krankenhäus
Altenpflege ambulante Pflege wie kann
man das steigern indem man auch die
Pflegenden endlich in die Strukturen
einbindet wir haben überhaupt kein
Mitspracherecht also Deutschland
verschwendet eigentlich jeden Tag die
Kompetenz der Pflegenden auch für das
Gesundheitssystem wir sind strukturell
können wir nicht mitbestimmen es gibt
große Gremien zum Beispiel gemeinsam
Bundesausschuss
qualitätsausschüsse und so weiter da
bestimmen alle über pflegerische
versorgungssituationen die Pflegenden
selbst aber haben keine Strukturen da
braucht man Gesetze da braucht man
Verordnungen da braucht man
heilberufegesetze kammergesetze damit
wir mitsprechen können diese fordern wir
seit Jahrzehnten die bekommen wir nicht
da geht es auch ein bisschen um
Strukturen im System um
Machtverhältnisse und das wäre ein
Schritt also man spricht über die
Pflegekräfte aber nicht mit ihnen was
ist denn immer mit der Idee Pflegekräfte
aus dem Ausland zu holen
ein Tropfen es gehört einer von den
Tropfen aber es ist natürlich auch
vermessen von uns erstmal brauchen
andere Länder auch die Pflegefachperson
und dann bis kommen die Menschen ich
arbeite sehr viel mit Kolleginnen die
aus dem Ausland kommen
anpassungslehrgängen zusammen und viele
kommen und sagen ich arbeite vier fünf
Jahre hier aber ich spreche die Sprache
Deutsch ist schwierig also das ist eine
Möglichkeit aber es ist nicht die Lösung
weil wir müssen hier vor Ort die
Bedingungen so verändern dass die jungen
Menschen wirklich und auch die alten
Menschen in die Pflege kommen ja großes
Problem
ist vor allen Dingen auch die
Gewinnorientierung dass die Pflege
natürlich privatisiert wurde aber das
ist ein armfüllendes Thema oder morgen
füllendes Thema für das nächste Gespräch
hier bei uns im Morgenmagazin Frau
Vogler vielen herzlichen Dank für Ihren
Besuch sehr gerne
[Applaus]